Ich glaube, es ist der in der Malerei
ganz gut aufgehoben, der …
der gleichzeitig sensibel ist oder
sanftmütig und rücksichtslos
und sich nicht drum kehrt, ob er
seine Eltern glücklich macht
oder ob er Geld verdient damit.
In Farbe getränkte Folien – Daniel Eltinger
setzt sie zu einem Kunstwerk zusammen.
Mehrere Wochen, manchmal Monate
arbeitet er an einem Bild.
Finanziell schau ich nicht weiter
als bis zum nächsten Monat.
Das geht mal gut, und mal
geht’s nicht so gut.
Keine Urlaubsreisen, wir sind
bedroht von Altersarmut.
Der Lohn der Malerei,
der liegt in der Malerei selber.
Dass wir die Freiheit haben, unser
Leben so zu gestalten, dass wir …
dass wir der Sache so dienen dürfen,
dass wir so ganz drin aufgehen dürfen.
Da liegen dann Ekstasen drin und
Freude, die aus Richtigkeit kommt.
Sich für Geld selbst zu vermarkten,
fällt Daniel Eltinger
wie vielen bildenden Künstlern schwer.
Seine Bilder sind ab 1500 Euro zu haben,
die Größeren kosten um die 6000.
Doch er verkauft meist nur
fünf bis sechs pro Jahr
und ist oft zusätzlich auf
Sozialhilfe angewiesen.
Die deutsche Hauptstadt Berlin zieht
seit Jahren Künstler aus aller Welt an.
Wer hier ausstellt, hat es geschafft.
Die Galerie „Eigen + Art“ ist eine der
Topadressen in Deutschland.
Galerist Gerd Harry Lybke vertritt
Malerstars wie Neo Rauch
und wurde so selbst berühmt.
Die Wände der Galerie sind leer, nur
eine Perlenkette liegt auf dem Boden.
Sie ist Teil einer Installation,
die 90.000 Euro kostet.
Konzeptkunst, zu der Daniel Eltinger
erst Zugang finden muss.
Daniel schaut sich gern Ausstellungen an.
Das inspiriert ihn.
Doch der kommerzielle Kunstbetrieb
bleibt ihm fremd.
Dabei müsste er eigentlich Teil davon sein.
Wir sind heutzutage so viele Künstler, dass
die sehr aus dem Vollen schöpfen können.
Müsste schon ein großer Zufall
sein – wie im Märchen.
Am besten man macht selber
’ne Galerie auf als junger Künstler
und man tut sich zusammen
und macht das.
Weil, jetzt: Wir nehmen jetzt nicht
irgendeinen Künstler auf oder so was,
sondern bei uns ist’s eher so, dass man
sagen könnte: Bitte rufen Sie uns nicht an,
wir rufen Sie an.
Also, wenn uns was hier im Team
auffällt oder ’n Künstler von uns sagt,
hey, guck dir das mal an, dann
guckt man sich das an.
Aber man hat auch gar keine Zeit,
all die Bewerbungen und all die Dinge,
die hereinkommen, sich anzusehen.
Der Kunstmarkt ist umkämpft, das
Angebot viel größer als die Nachfrage.
Daniel Eltinger verkauft seine
Bilder bisher eher zufällig,
vor allem an Freunde, Bekannte
und einige wenige Sammler.
Ich glaube, das wär mir gar nicht möglich,
dass ich …
dass ich was so male,
dass es sich leichter verkauft.
Der Betrachter soll erwarten dürfen,
dass das Gemälde möglichst es selbst ist,
dass es nach seinen eigenen
Werdebedingungen entwickelt wurde.
Die Freiheit, das machen zu dürfen, was
ich machen will, die ist mir das Kostbarste.
Dafür nimmt man dann es in Kauf,
dass man nicht so mitmachen kann
mit den anderen, wie …
wie es so üblich ist.